frustration of a high unemployment and
inflation that is why some people didn't
leave the queue despite long delays some
polling stations in Zimbabwe opened and
closed on time but in others ballot
papers arrived at the end of the day we
are hungry
so that he can vote it's for being
active from South Africa to come and
vote because it's my right to vote
election officials say some ballot
papers were printed late because of
Court challenges there are several
polling stations here election officials
say it's meant to make the voting
process smoother so lines can move
faster but they are logistical
challenges some polling stations in
parts of the country opened late
president Emerson managawa is confident
he will be re-elected if I think I'm not
going to take it then I'll be foolish
everyone who contests if you're going to
rest you're going to rest to win and the
precession is what I'm doing
his main rival Nelson Chamisa is also
confident but says the delays are
suspicious I'm saying to Zimbabwe be
patient be vigilant oh don't be
frustrated you must make sure you
exercise your body this is a repeat of
what they did in 2002 they are trying to
confuse people but the people know what
they want
to win the presidency a candidate must
get more than 50 percent of the vote if
there is no outright winner a runoff
between the top two candidates will be
held in October the Electoral commission
says polling stations that opened late
will close later Harare
foreign